dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir earlier we
talked about google's wavenet a
learning-based text-to-speech engine
this means that we give it a piece of
written text and after a training step
using someone's voice it has to read it
aloud using this person's voice as
convincingly as possible and this
follow-up work is about making it even
more convincing before we go into it
let's marvel at these new results
together
generative adversarial network or
variational auto-encoder he has read the
whole thing
he reads books
this is really awesome
this is your personal assistant Google
home
this is your personal assistant Google
home
the buses aren't the problem they
actually provide a solution the buses
aren't the problem they actually provide
a solution
she sells seashells on the seashore the
shells she sells are seashells I'm sure
mm-hmm
as you can hear it is great at prosody
stress and intonation which leads to
really believable human speech
the magic component in the original
wavelet paper was introducing dilated
convolutions for this problem this makes
large skips in the input data so we have
a better global view of it it is a bit
like increasing the receptive field of
the eye so we can see the entire
landscape and not only a tree on a
photograph the magic component in this
new work is using mouse spectrograms as
an input to wavelet this is an
intermediate representation that is
based on the human perception that
records not only how different words
should be pronounced but expected
volumes and intonation as well the new
model was trained on about 24 hours of
speech data and of course no research
work should come without some sort of
validation the first is recording the
mean opinion scores for previous
algorithms this one in real professional
voice recordings the mean opinion score
is a number that describes how a sound
sample would pass as genuine human
speech the new algorithm passed with
flying colors and even more practical
evaluation was also done in the form of
a user study where people were listening
to the synthesized samples and
professional voice narrators and had to
guess which one is which and this is
truly incredible because most of the
time people had no idea which was which
if you don't believe it we'll try this
ourselves in a moment
very small but statistically significant
tendency towards favoring the real
footage was recorded likely because some
words like Merlot or mispronounced
automatically voice audiobooks automatic
voice narration for video games bring it
on
what a time to be alive note that
producing these waveforms is not real
time and still takes quite a while to
progress along that direction scientists
a deep mind wrote a heck of a paper
where they spared wavenet up a thousand
times leave a comment if you would like
to hear more about it in a future
episode and of course new inventions
like this will also
new challenges down the line it may be
that voice recordings will become much
easier to forge and be less useful as
evidence unless we find new measures to
verify their authenticity for instance
to sign them like we do with software in
closing a few audio sample pairs one of
them is real one of them is synthesized
what do you think which is which leave a
comment below that girl did a video
about Star Wars lipstick
girl did a video about Star Wars
lipstick
she earned a doctorate in sociology at
Columbia University
she earned a doctorate in sociology at
Columbia University
George Washington was the first
president of the United States George
Washington was the first president of
the United States I'm too busy for
romance
I'm too busy for romance
I'll just leave a quick hint here that I
found on the web page up there you go if
you have enjoyed this episode please
make sure to support us on patreon this
is how we can keep the show running and
you know the drill
$1 is almost nothing but it keeps the
papers coming thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time
[Music]